I CAN I PLEASE EXECUTIVE
IS A SERGEANT PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
AND THEN SECRETARY PLEASE
TOTAL SANTIAGO AIRED OBERNOLTE
HERE BONTA CERVANTES AND
WHAT IT DOES TO YOU HOLDEN
KAMLAGER-DOVE PAIRED UP HELLO
VENTURE THERE THIS YEAR SEN
TO GET OFF YOUR CLOTHES SO FAR
YES RIGHT HERE
YES NO WAS NO I DON'T
COUNTY SAN ANTONIO TRIPTYCHS
OKAY
TAKE A FOURTH CALL I FELT FOR
SORRY WE HAVE ONE ITEM
ON THE AGENDA IT'S AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR MISTER
THANK YOU ARE SURE IF YOU LET
ME FOR ALLOWS ON THE FRANCISCO
BEAUTIFULLY THE SEPARATIST
CHARGING PRO RIVAL IN THAT
WERE CUT BRING THAT FORWARD
AND VOTERS IN THE NOVEMBER
TWENTY HACKING ELECTION WAS A
TWO THIRDS VOTE VOTERS WOULD
HAVE THIS JOHN BRING THAT
WAS BROKERED BY A SUPERVISOR
IN PESKIN TO FOR HIS BILL
BALLOT MEASURE OFF THE BALLOT
COMES NEW YOUNG THIS NOVEMBER
IS ABLE TO REACH AGREEMENT
THE DIFFERENT TRANSPORTATION
NETWORK COMPANIES TO BRING
THIS BILL FORWARD UMF WHILE
WE ARE CHARTER CITY AND WE
BELIEVE THAT WOULD QUIRK PROPER
BOUGHT A HOUSE BUSINESS FOR
YOU GOING IN STATE ELECTIONS
ACTUALLY VERY VERY QUICKLY
WE HAVE UTILITY SHE'D GO AND
TO DO THIS AND I GET FOUR TWO
ENVELOPES OF WITHOUT PRIOR
I'VE BEEN ANSWERING QUESTIONS
DRIVING A VEHICLE THANK YOU
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT YES
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JOSHUA
SHOP FOR VISITING COUNTY THIS
WAS MAYOR OF LONDON BREED WHO
COMMANDS THIS COLLABORATIVE
PROCESS BETWEEN CITY OUR
ELECTED OFFICIALS AND MEMBERS
OF OUR STATE DELEGATION AND
THE TRANSPORTATION NETWORK
COMPANIES TO MERRILEES THIS
COLLABORATION DEMONSTRATES
WE CAN ADVANCE SOLUTIONS TO
OUR MOST CHALLENGING CONCERNS
CLEARING CONGESTION INCLUDING
A PUBLIC TRANSIT THAT'S MY
THE MAYOR PLUS RETAIN FORCE
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE
THANK CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR OF
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE YEAH
FOR WORKING WITH US IT WAS
BUILT ON THIS POINT ABSOLUTELY
EIGHTY FOUR AS A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION TO HELP ENSURE
THAT OUR STREETS ARE SAFE
GROWING MOBILE USERS AND TRAIN
THANK YOU ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT IN SUPPORT
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WILL RESULT
OF THAT UBER USERS OF THE
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL SAYS YOUR
HEART A FIVE DEGREE DO YOU
SEE ANY SENSE IS GOING TO
PROVIDE FUNDING AND IT ALSO I
LIKE THE FACT THAT SEX IS GOOD
CITY THAT CITIES IN POPULATION
ERICSSON SO MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TO THINK CHAIR AND
AND THE OTHER THE TAIL AND ALL
THE ADVOCATES -- IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL TRIGGERING A REALLY
NEED A RESOURCE ISSUE VERY FEW
FASHION SHOW VOTERS SUPPORT
THE MEASURE CREE AFTER HE'S
ANYONE IS OPPOSITION YES
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CAN
INDIVIDUAL ACTUALLY GROUPS HERE
THIS EVENING HOWARD JARVIS HAD
HERE'S AS ALL THE OTHER EXTREME
OUR STUDENTS NONPROFIT THINK
BASED OUT OF WASHINGTON SEE
WITHOUT I HAVE FOCUSED ON THAT
FREE MARKET -- INDIVIDUALISTIC
SOLUTION WE GAVE HUNDRED TIMES
BEFORE -- AND OCCUPATIONAL
LICENSING AS A PROVINCE TO
THIS BILL WE ARE VERY CONCERNED
I TAX AUTHORIZATION DOES
WORKER COPPER HE IS GOING
TO STIFLE CITY STREET IN THE
CITY AND FURTHERMORE AS IT
PERTAINS I THOUGHT IF YOU HAVE
GOALS SAID VEHICLES MEMBERS
ESPECIALLY AS SOMEONE HERE
WITH DISABILITY YEAH BECAUSE
ARE INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE I THINK VALUABLE
AND IMPORTANT PART OF THE
COMMUNITIES IN I HAVE GEN
EXTENDER SITE FOR MANY PATIENTS
AND DOCTORS AND HIGHER THIS
CLEAR PROBLEM FOR ALL THOSE WHO
ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES OPPOSITION
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHEN MR
Ở I APOLOGIZE -- EVERYTHING
ALL UNDER OUR CONCERN
ARE CONCERNED THREE THE STATE
THE WAR CITY IT COULD BE
APPLIED THAT ALREADY HAS TURNED
SO IT'S GREAT TO STEP DOWN
QUESTIONS ABOUT CHARTER THINGS
THAT CREATES THAT CREATES E.
PLEASE SAME AS AND THREE
WOULD HAVE LIKED TO SEE THAT'S
ABOUT PLEASE RIGHT HERE YOU
KNOW IN THIS CASE THE STATE'S
CURRENT RESEARCH GREENHOUSE
GAS POOLS CERTAINLY DAYS ON
AND OUR PEOPLE ISNT TREATS LIKE
YOUR VEHICLES LIKE CONVENTIONAL
AND OTHER JURISDICTIONS
CAROLINE ALL HUNCHED OVER
HALF OF THE IN W.
NORTH AMERICA WE ARE ALSO
PROPOSING THAT WE HAVE
THE FACT ELECTION WITH A
MANDATE TO SELL CARS AND
THIS COST TABLE RIVER FOUGHT
AT ACCEPTED AN OFFER WITH
RESPECT TO TIME IS THE NEXT
THING THAT HAPPENED BACK
JOHN BECAUSE OF THE HALF AWAKE
HUNDREDS WHO WERE TALK ABOUT WE
DO SECOND SECOND WAIT A SECOND
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MITCHELL
ORTEGA'S CHAIR MISTER TING
SO THE WHOLE REASON WHY THIS
COMMITTEE EXERCISES OVERSIGHT
OVER CONVEYANCE IN THE STATE
IS TO SET STATEWIDE REGULATION
AND AVOID THE PATCHWORK OF
DIFFERENT LOCAL REGULATIONS
IN DIFFERENT AREAS NOT DISPEL
APPLIES ONLY TO A SINGLE CITY
AND SEEMS TO BE A SIGNIFICANT
DEPARTURE FROM THE PAST CUSTOM
AND PRACTICE OF THE REGULATION
OF THIS INDUSTRY SO AND EXPLAIN
WHY IT'S NECESSARY JUST FOR
THIS ONE CITY TO TAKE THIS
ACTION THIS CD ON MY THINGS
WHERE HE'S TO HOWEVER START
CRYSTAL HEADQUARTERS GARCIA
AND THIS TECHNOLOGY THESE
COMPANIES ARE REALLY STARTED
IN SAN FRANCISCO SINCE WE
HAVE ON REALLY -- FOR THE
BROAD AND GROWING DISPENSED
SIGNIFICANT GROWING PAINS OF
OUR RELATIONSHIP CITY POINT
OF VIEW AT LEAST TWO COMPANIES
SO WHAT I WOULD SAY THIS IS
A VERY HISTORIC AGREEMENT AT
TIMES AND AT THE TIME GRACIOUS
GOOD PUNCHES AND CONTENTIOUS
THIS REALLY UNCONSCIONABLE
CHAPTER IN THAT RELATIONSHIP
WHERE THE COMPANIES ARE COMING
TOGETHER POINT B.
PART OF THE SOLUTION MONEY
WERE REASONABLE GO INTO TRANSIT
AS WELL AS PEDESTRIAN BICYCLE
SAFETY I KNOW MISTER MOORE HAD
MENTIONED HIS CONCERN FOR ON
THE SIDES OF THE PARENTS JUST
FOR EXAMPLE BASED ON WHO RATES
I SUPPOSE IN LEGISLATION YOU
A TWENTY DOLLAR MY IF YOU WERE
AN INDIVIDUAL I WOULD GET SICK
FIVE CENTS AND IF YOU ARE IN
THE RIGHT SHARE SITUATION YOU
CAN POINT OWNERSHIP YOUR FEE
HIS THIRTIES SO I CAN ONLY
THINK THIS FEE IS MANY OF
US BUT YEAH I WILL GIVE YOU
WOULD MEAN SIGNIFICANTLY LESS
ABOUT THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
WE DON'T BELIEVE IT WILL
HAPPEN ON ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
INDUSTRY OBVIOUSLY AS A CITY
WE ARE FILTER EXTRAORDINARILY
BIỂU BONTA FUNDAMENTALLY
WATCHING COURAGE MORE LIES YOUR
MISSION CRITICAL FUNCTION AND
NOTHING LIKE MAJOR PRIORITY
FOR CODIFIED IN THE LEGISLATURE
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES MAY BE
CHARGED LAST I THINK THAT WAS
PART OF UNDERSTANDING WHAT
THE AGREEMENT WAS PURPOSELY
LEFT THE LEGISLATION LITTLE
I UNDERSTAND YOU MORE BECAUSE
SHE NEGOTIATION CYCLICAL VOCAL
ON THE BALLOT FOR NEXT ON THE
STREET WE REALLY ENCOURAGE ALL
THE VARIOUS OPPONENTS WHO ARE
HERE REPRESENTING VERY SERIOUS
HEART ATTACK PART OKAY BUT
BUT COUNTY WE'VE WE'VE ORDERED
WAS MORE THE BRUNT OF THIS
SHE WISHES FOR A VERY PROUD
OF THAT PEOPLE VERY PROPER
INFLATION BUT THE SAME TIME
EXTENSIVE MEDICAL MY FIRST
BOB I'VE I FEAR THAT THE SETS
A TERRIBLE PRECEDENT YEAH
MAKING CODIFYING INDIVIDUAL
REGULATIONS FOR INDIVIDUAL
CITIES I DON'T THINK THAT'S
THE PURPOSE OF THIS COMMITTEE
SO POPULARIZED BY PROPOSITION
AND ALRIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
RIGHT HEARING NONE REVERSED
MOTION A SECOND MEADOW PURPLISH
COLORING WITH RECOMMENDATIONS
SENATE SANTIAGO OBERNOLTE NO
OBERNOLTE NO BONTA AYE BONTA
HIGH CERVANTES CHAU CERVANTES
NOW EDUARDO GARCIA HOLDEN
HOLDEN I KAMLAGER-DOVE CURRENT
COMMANDER DOWN BEHIND LOS FIVE
LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS CHINA
KNOWS MATHIS MATHIS NONPARTISAN
VOTERS HAVE SAID NO HOPE SO
BUT NO RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
IT'S A PLEASURE
THE SAME ARTICLE
RIGHT -- THE COUNTY IS
THE TAIL IS FIVE AYE SIX
KNOWS THAT PHILOSOPHICAL
WITH
BUT TAYLOR NDA SO
CHILDREN ASKS US